[Musica]
e stato l'applauso più facile nella mia
vita io non sono uno speaker sono un
cosiddetto artista allora vuol dire che
non dovete stare attenti non sarà
chiesto durante l'esame
questo è solo per divertimento perché
sono uno scrittore io leggo quando i
distinti illustri eminenti serenissimi e
illuminati organizzatori di questo
importantissimo evento mi hanno onorato
con la loro richiesta
incredibilmente lusinghiera di usufruire
dal loro palco per rivolgere alcune
parole sul tema della vita nuova
temo di aver dimostrato l'insolenza di
chiedere umilmente a loro se
intendessero un discorso sull'amore
interpretando la vita nuova in chiave
dantesca oppure se avrebbero preferito
un altro soggetto
mi hanno gentilmente risposto che alla
luce del fatto che sono tra i pochi
stranieri su questo palco e considerando
la circostanza che l'ho appena
pubblicato un romanzo sul nostro vecchio
continente la nostra gioia e l'identità
europea sarebbe stato preferibile un
breve discorso sull'europa
dopo di aver superato la mia delusione
per questa infallibile saggezza dei
stimati celebri e simili esimi alti e
onorevole organizzatori ho avuto
l'audacia idea di combinare le due cose
e di presentarvi la mia
g razione d'amore per l'europa perché ci
vuole proprio oggi è forse più
necessario che mai superare la vergogna
dettata dall opinione pubblica fare un
coming out e non avere paura di
dichiarare apertamente l'amore per il
nostro vecchio continente e il suo
futuro come unione sempre più stretta è
necessario perché non va di moda il
separatismo della break site
l'euroscetticismo vanno di moda il
separatismo deriva dalla nostalgia di
tempi migliori che non importa se siano
davvero esistiti o meno è seducente
pensare che la soluzione ai problemi di
oggi si trovi nel tirare indietro gli
orologi al giorno in cui quei problemi
non esistevano ancora
quello è il richiamo dal populismo di
destra che per natura e nostalgico
vengono create fomentate ingigantite
insoddisfazioni e paure per poi
presentare come soluzione un passato
idillico è realizzato dobbiamo tornare a
chiudere le frontiere reintrodurre la
nostra cara vecchia moneta far risuonare
le nostre campane e chiudere le moschee
ripristinare il servizio militare
obbligatorio cantare l'inno nazionale e
scovare dalla soffitta il nostro decoro
di una volta e lucida lo fina fan un
faro sfavillante nella notte buia
che questo è un messaggio nostalgico
trovi risonanza di massa in tutta europa
è un cattivo segno se una parte
significativa e crescente della
popolazione è pronta a credere che una
volta tutto era meglio possiamo a
ragione a parlare di un continente
diventato vecchio e stanco che come un
vecchio fissa nel vuoto senza attendersi
più niente da un futuro e ripensa ai bei
tempi in cui l'inverno faceva ancora
freddo e le estati non finivano mai non
esiste dimostrazione migliore della tesi
che l'europa è diventata prigioniera del
proprio passato ma quando l'occidente
sprofonda nella malinconia pensando al
sole brillante che l'inu il illuminava
quando era allo zenit
la nostalgia non può in alcun caso
essere il rimedio
io non penso di poter vivere fuori
dall'europa
credo di pensare che ne sono sicuro
in europa dove l'unica certezza è che si
deve credere nel pensiero dove nel corso
di una lunga e faticosa storia si sono
provate da cosi tante soluzioni
definitive che si sono cominciati ad
amare i problemi dove in mancanza di una
giustificazione convincente per
giustificare il dinamismo si attribuisce
valore allo stile dove sono stati
inventati sia lo snobismo che em ironia
dove le cicatrici sono belle perché
rendono prudenti dove in nome degli
ideali si è rasato così tanto sangue che
sia cominciato a imporre requisiti agli
ideali dove da quando le chiacchiere
sono incominciate 2500 anni fa intorno a
mare egeo non si ha ancora trovato un
accordo sulle definizioni e i
presupposti di una discussione sensata
su bello e il buono e la verità dove il
dubbio è religione dove ne vivono più
filosofi che camerieri per servirli e
più poetiche lettori dove ogni paesaggio
ogni città e le guance di ogni donna
sono invecchiati dietro il crack e lei
dove ho passato è tangibile come la
pietra e le strat e leggibili come un
palinsesto dove i nomi sono echi dove
tutti i regni del passato sono trascorsi
come stagioni dove tutto
è già stato più volte molto meglio è
molto più bello d ora
e dove a pensarci bene ci si meriterebbe
di riposare dopo tutto il lavoro
compiuto per riempire di così tanti
dettagli li anali di una storia
millenaria è là che io posso respirare
ea mare se devo essere patriottico
voglio essere un patriota paradossale
del mosaico è in decadenza di piccoli
paesi pur ilmenite divisi tra l'oceano
atlantico e li vola urali dove un
patriottismo ha già scavato così tante
tombe da non essere più una virtù
voglio essere un patriota dell'unione
europea che lotta giorno dopo giorno
contro sorpassati interessi nazionali e
coraggiosamente continua a lottare
nessuno sa ma l'unione europea ma io sì
amo la lentezza poetica e l'ostinazione
valorosa con cui viene data forma a
questa meraviglia di complessità e di
compromessi anche la costruzione del
duomo di milano duro 400 anni e anche se
l'europa nella corsa la crescita
economica o progresso e o futuro resta
rivettata al suo passato come uno sprint
trattenuto da una molla blocco di
partenza e viene sorpassato da ogni lato
dal resto del mondo
io do ragione
all'europa che si rifiuta di abbandonare
il suo passato perché le radici sono più
importanti delle destinazioni che gli
altri siano pure dei lemming noi siamo
un pino nato storto e all ombra di per
pino dove nel corso dei secoli si sono
già seduti così tanti poeti li posso
scrivere altrove l'inchiostro della mia
penna se crede per poter respirare
pensare e scrivere
devo continuare a dialogare con la
traduzione o bisogno dell'europa per
poter resistere
l'unica risposta alla nostalgia del
nazionalismo e la nostra zia di una
europa che dialoga come gli umanisti di
una volta e che si unisce nella
diversità della sua cultura millenaria
l'unica risposta la nostalgia di un
continente prigioniero da proprio
passato e sognare un futuro radicato e
in quello che lui dice già da tanto
tempo
il suo patrimonio artistico
bisogna avere il coraggio di essere
nostalgici di un futuro migliore e di
una vita nuova per l'europa nell'amore
dell'unione radicata nella cultura
vi ringrazio
[Applauso]